so do you do you feel like um having a
high body count as a girl has
consequences
um i think it does um i i think it does
and like even from experience i think
that's like some guys will be like this
turns me off but then i'm like okay then
you're you're yeah
i think compatibility is so important so
would you tell a young woman to sleep
around and like explore their sexuality
or would you tell them to keep your body
count as low as possible so you can get
the best quality husband
um
i would say what what is important to
you
and some people that's it some people
see some people sleep around for
validation and they'll be like don't do
that right don't do that like please
like don't do that like i have had
casual sex because i enjoy sex that's
that's the right long and short of it i
enjoy sex
um
female sexual liberation i'm all here
for it yeah um but i used to be very
codependent because it was all dependent
upon my self-worth was dependent upon
being desirable to a man and i got to a
point in like late 2020 where i was like
i don't want to do that anymore because
i've either been undervalued or
underappreciated and i ended up in
relationships where i thought the men
were my league
but they didn't respect me so then i
dated men who were under my league who
adored me and then i was like you're not
enough
well do you yeah do you think maybe they
were actually your league because like
you can't say that someone was your
league if they weren't able to commit to
you like your league is who you can get
to commit to you but then this comes to
the success and ambition and blah blah
blah
right but remember men and women are
valued for different things yeah so
i settled for men that were short and
broke
i settled for men but they could say
like they settled for you with a high
body count but like they could they
could say the same thing but they are
men that literally the men that i
settled for were men that literally were
like they look at me in the morning and
be like you're the most beautiful person
in the world and i was like no i'm not
you're correct i you i was like you
literally you expect too too little i
guess you simpson behavior i guess
behavior
behavior yeah like i was gonna say i
think there is a i think there is a
middle yeah between um between
uh a girl getting a guy
because i get what you're saying yeah
like
for for girls your league isn't who you
can sleep with your league is who you
can get
to commit to you but what i would say is
that a lot of girls date guys who could
have committed to them but because
they've dated them in a certain way
they've put themselves in the friends of
benefit zone so now that's not
on the table does that make sense so i
think there is like you know for sure
like there is like a you know like oh if
a guy's a nine and he's sleeping with a
girl who's quoting quite a five that
she's probably never gonna commit to her
right but it's possible that okay if a
guy is an eight who gets a lot of
attention he may sleep with a girl as an
a but if she
plays it wrong you might think oh she's
hot
like she's very attractive because she's
not girlfriend i think guys go down and
looks all the time i'm not like dis but
just sex yeah i'm not discounting that
but what i'm saying like as a girl it's
still what you can get to commit because
that's still you it's your choices yeah
right it's true but i think i think
girls don't um
i think a lot of girls
do date guys who could have committed to
them it's just because the way they
dated them the guy was like well she's
not girlfriend material yeah and then
this does come back to body count
because i've had an experience where
recently a guy is like well i've not
dated anyone since you i get a bit
jealous when you tell me you want to end
things i'm like but you've told me
you're not gonna commit to me you're not
gonna be serious about me i'm never
gonna be your girlfriend i'm like but
you are serious about me and to be fair
body count doesn't actually relate to
our situation
but
oh there's just so many like
really like intricate details and it's
not it's not necessarily like practical
in this day and age right because again
the average age of first marriage was
27. like guys used to marry virgins and
now like guys don't even like want
virgins yeah but that's it it's that
whole
whole black and white situation where a
guy you know
a lot of it's about ego and a lot of it
yeah a lot of it is about people's
self-worth and self-esteem
and i did have a really good point to
say oh it's about um attractiveness even
that so i
used to go off of the ethos to a blind
person with all the same so i gave a lot
of people chances and i used to go on
dates with anyone because i just don't
do that i'm like
don't don't do it this sounds so awful
but like so i did that i was like
give them pity sex like
i used to piss
you say that i used to pick not so i
used to pity kiss people i give people
my phone number and be like i don't
really want to give you my phone but
maybe if you're showing me interest
and a guy so this is why i say
undervalued or underwhelmed yeah so that
was what i ended up in i used to be like
guys that i thought were like my level
my league would like not value me
and then guys that were who really
adored me loved me really valued me i
was like oh you're underwhelming i don't
think that you match up and that's why
i've been single single by choice for a
year and a half because i'm like i don't
want to get hurt i don't i don't want to
hurt anyone but i don't get hurt and i
was like i'm actually you're also you're
being alone you're also competing for a
small percentage of guys too that you're
probably attracted you know that only
like ten percent i don't even i don't
know the exact stat but
i've heard numbers from five to fifteen
percent of dating app swipes are i don't
use dating apps
because dating apps do tend to be a
black and white party in that you've
either got people on there who are like
i just want something casual nice not
nothing serious
um or you've got people who are like i'm
looking for a relationship so you've got
two types of processing you've got top
down or bottom up top down processing
and people who are like i want a
relationship ergo i'm looking for
someone who can
fill that criteria so when they go on
dates when they swipe they're like i'm
literally thinking about
are you going through relation material
or
there's people like me i'm bottom up
where i'm like i'd rather just meet
someone and be like where is this going
to go let's live in there now let's take
it date by date time but you think that
women it would be better for women if we
dated more intentionally
because to me it's like if you could be
single you could be single let's say
you're single for five years or in a
relationship for five years
like i would think that the girl would
probably be less like
heartbroken and have less trauma if she
was in a relationship for five years
because i mean assuming he's not
narcissist assuming assuming there's no
abuse narcissism like any of that stuff
because if you're just like dating
around like like i don't know like at
some point you're gonna get rejected by
guys that like don't call you back or
like you you know what i'm saying like
[ __ ] like that happens all the time
better is subjective like eat pray love
is based on a real life story where
she's she's married she's successful
yeah she's like i'm actually not happy
i'm actually not like i'd like to circle
back with that lady yeah that turned out
yeah
and it's like
there are people who sometimes wake up
and go [ __ ] i'm not happy and i should
be happy i hate the concept of should
and so i'm i'm a really big advocate for
like difference do you do you think
happiness like comes and goes oh yeah
like like do you think you should just
leave a relation a relationship with
like kids and stuff if you're not happy
so i was gonna i was gonna say would you
here's a question would you sacrifice
happiness for fulfillment
yeah
would you because i think happened like
you said happiness can go up and down
yeah like it's an emotion right it comes
it's not happiness isn't a
permanent state that you can be in but
you can be content and fulfilled what
you have
but we just sacrifice happiness for
fulfillment
then it depends like for me
happiness
is probably
oh no to be fair happiness isn't
dependent on fulfillment but i'm always
over the obvious like we could die
tomorrow and if you're not happy and if
you're not like content if you're not if
you're not a whole
individual
then anything else that you like put
yourself into like
i don't know it's a really tough that's
it nothing is ever black that's it going
back that nothing is black and white
right or wrong better or worse
um
nothing's right or wrong but like it's
that grey area of like in some
situations i'd probably be like i'll
sacrifice happiness for like even when
you study or you you do a job if you do
a job you know that's interesting i
think if you ask men the same question
most of them would say yes i think women
care a lot more about being happy and
men care a lot more about being
fulfilled well that's like because i
think i think it's not about like you
especially if you have a family it's not
about you anymore like doesn't she leave
does she leave a husband and kids and
eat pray love
uh she needs a husband
a husband and a job yeah like i don't
know i think that's that's a bit selfish
you're leaving a commitment you made for
what to go like go to india but to be
selfish means that we're prioritizing
what everyone else wants compared to
what we want yeah but sometimes what you
want isn't right like emotions come and
go people leave that's it right and
wrong very subjective there's it's all
about that gray area walking the middle
path right and wrong to one person so
that's it genocide and racism to one
person is right uh-huh like
things to one person are correct and you
could argue to your blue in the face and
be like that's not correct and they
literally will be like like that's it
hitler hitler literally what is she it's
not even right correct i think there's
consequences and i i i'd really like to
circle back with that later yeah
she made a book she made a lot of money
it might have worked out yeah yeah
she made back because yeah so you know
what i mean maybe she did but i don't
think the average woman that makes that
decision it's going to end up well for
her no no not at all and that's why
you've got to be cognizant of
differences and privileges uh
circumstances and things like that so
yeah the average woman could not be like
i'm not happy in my job or my marriage
or being a mum yeah because then you're
like well [ __ ]
finances your your marriage your family
like your kids and the average woman
could not do that
um but does it mean that she shouldn't
want to or she like it's just like uh
but then you get stuck
being like are you living for yourself
or are you living for others are you
living for expectations i think it's
okay
i think it's okay to live for others and
i'll give you an example okay yeah i
live a lot for my dad's approval like a
lot i care a lot what my dad thinks like
a lot and i do a lot of things not
because i want to but because he wants
me to and i don't mean like
like i would i'm doing this clearly
because i love this yeah he doesn't care
about social media but just in terms of
like like my last boyfriend my dad
didn't like and that really bothered me
it bothered me a lot because i love my
dad and i think like there's some things
it's okay
it's almost a good thing to like put you
know values and like your commitments
and like your word above what makes you
happy at the time yeah i i was gonna say
i think the difference between people
today and people back in the day is that
we back in the day people all about
community yeah it was all about doing
what's best for the community it was all
about doing what's best for your family
whereas now
i think
i think back then we didn't have enough
individualism
that people were sacrificing a lot of
their happiness for their community but
now we've gone the other way where
there's so much individualism now yeah
that people are no longer contributing
or even care about their local community
or their family and their nuclear family
which is why people leave
et cetera et cetera so i i agree and
you know i'm my family are nigerian and
in our culture like once you have kids
it's about them you do what's best for
them so
if you but you staying with your partner
is what's best for the kids and you can
make that work that's what you do until
they leave then you split up or whatever
i actually i always say people always
ask me if i'd stay with a cheater and i
always say no unless
there were kids
interesting why'd you say that because
if they're kids it's not about me